En este vídeo quiero tratar acerca de puras gráficas de funciones cuadráticas,
y para eso tengo estos planos cartesianos que estoy dibujando a la derecha. Sin embargo quiero
repasar algo que vimos en el vídeo pasado, en el cual cometí un pequeño error
y ya no lo pude corregir de youtube, y por lo tanto se quedó este error ahí en el vídeo.
Cuando yo ponía que tenía algo de la forma
f de "x" más "g" que
multiplicaba a hx más "j", se acuerdan en el vídeo pasado lo vimos, y esto me quedaba de resultado fhx cuadrada
fhx y "x" por "x" era "x"
cuadrada y justo aquí estaba mi error, por que no puse este cuadrado, se me olvidó ¡Perdón, perdón! Estaba muy despistado a la vez pasada,
y no puse este cuadrado. Y después me quedaba "f"
por "x" por "j", me quedaba fjx, y después "g" por "h" por "x" me quedara ghx y por
último me quedaba,
gj ¿Se acuerdan? Esto lo habíamos visto en el vídeo pasado y el vídeo pasado
omití este cuadrado que estaba aquí y por lo tanto pues parece que no era una función cuadrática pero, en efecto
era una función cuadrática y ahora que me doy cuenta de mi error, quiero
compartirselos y poner un poco de cara de pena, por que olvidé este cuadrado pero bueno,
no es el tema de esta ocasión. En esta ocasión quiero ver
gráficas de puras funciones cuadráticas. ¿Cómo se grafican funciones cuadráticas? Algo como por este estilo.
Supongamos que yo tengo una función "y" es igual a "x" cuadrada -2x -8
y bueno lo primero que quiero que te des cuenta es que aquí tenemos una función que es cuadrática.
Tenemos "x" cuadrada -2x -8, por lo tanto mi gráfica no va a ser una línea recta ¿Qué nos va a salir de gráfica de esta función?
Bueno nos va a salir algo de este estilo.
Y bueno el menú a seguir, va a ser el siguiente. Lo que voy a buscar son las
intersecciones con el eje de las "x" y después voy a encontrar el vértice. Ya vas a ver lo que es el vértice en un segundo.
Antes lo que quiero ver es cómo se factoriza esta expresión, y voy a buscar 2 números que
multiplicados me den - 8 y que sumados me den -2 y creo que funciona con -4 y 2 positivo.
-4 por 2 me da - 8
y -4 más 2 me da -2x.
¡Perfecto! Por lo tanto esto se puede factorizar como "x" -4 que multiplica a "x" más 2
a "x" más 2 y bueno lo primero que voy a hacer, es buscar
cuáles son las intersecciones con el eje de las "x" y para esto voy a buscar los valores de "x"
tales que "y" valga 0, por que si te das cuenta, cuando
interceptamos al eje de las "x" lo que estamos diciendo es que "y" vale 0, no estamos subiendo nada. Lo único que estamos haciendo es
buscando valores de "x" por lo tanto voy a hacer esta función igual a 0.
0 es igual a "x" - 4 por "x" más 2 y esto ya lo habíamos visto, si teníamos 2 binomios
multiplicándose que eran iguales a 0,
queríamos decir que o el primero es 0, o el segundo es 0, o "x" -4 es igual a 0 o en su lado caso
"x" más 2 es igual a 0 y bueno en el primero me queda que "x" es igual a 4, paso del otro lado el
4 sumando, y en el otro caso me queda que "x" es igual a -2, si restó -2, de los dos lados me
queda que "x" es igual a -2 y ya tengo mis 2 raíces de esta ecuación, o ya tengo mis 2 valores para
los cuales esta ecuación se hace 0, o dicho de otra manera ya encontré aquellos valores o mejor aún, aquellos puntos en donde
interceptamos al eje de las "x" el 4,0 y el -2,0.
Así que vamos a graficarlos.  Así que déjenme tomar un color un poco más
fuerte para graficar esta función, y me va a quedar los puntos 4,0 que es este de aquí y -2,0
que va a ser este de por acá, -1 -2, 0.
Muy bien entonces por aquí va a pasar mi parábola y más aún por aquí
intersecta mi parábola al eje de las "x". Ahora a continuación lo que quiero pensar es cuánto vale el valor del vértice de mi parábola,
por que el vértice de mi parábola
curiosamente tiene como valor en "x" al punto medio entre estos 2 puntos
y que esas vértices de una parábola bueno, alguna vez vimos que todas las funciones cuadráticas se veían de esta forma.
Estas son parábolas y esta que estoy dibujando aquí es su vértice,
su vértice es su valor más pequeño, es decir el mínimo de esta función o en su dado caso su vértice sube el valor más
grande  de esta función
por lo tanto es un máximo de esta función, y estas 2 son parábolas, son parábolas por que son las gráficas que nos quedan al graficar
ecuaciones cuadráticas,
siempre que tengamos una ecuación cuadrática como ésta, nos va a quedar una parábola y entonces fíjate bien, si nosotros interceptamos
aquí en el eje de las "x", siempre nos va a quedar el vértice en medio de estos dos
valores de "x" o dicho de otra manera, el punto medio pensado en "x" va a ser aquel punto
al cual va a corresponder mi "x", entonces vamos a calcularlo. "X" del vértice ¿Quién va a ser?
"X" y déjame ponerlo mejor, si si así lo voy a poner, "x" del vértice es igual a 4
-2 entre 2 es decir el punto medio en "x",
entre estos 2 valores que habíamos sacado cuando nosotros interceptamos con el eje de las "x", 4 más-2 entre 2 me queda
1, 4 menos 2 es 2, 2 entre 2 es 1,
entonces cuando "x" vale 1 nosotros tenemos nuestro vértice. Ahora sería muy bueno saber cuánto vale el valor de "y" de
nuestro vértice y bueno vamos a sustituir en nuestra ecuación que tenemos aquí arriba.
1, - 2, - 8 por que es 1 al cuadrado -2 por 1, -8 y 1 - 2 me da - 1, -1-8 me da
-9 y entonces ya tengo el punto de mi vértice.
Así que el punto 1,-9 es el punto del vértice de mi parábola.
1,-9,- 1, - 2, - 3, - 4, - 5, -6, - 7, -8, -9.
Estamos parados aquí,
perfecto este es el vértice de mi parábola y por lo tanto ya sabemos cómo va a mi parábola.
Este es mi vértice y ahora lo que se me ocurre es pues graficar mi parábola.
Este es el punto más bajo de mi parábola y si te das cuenta está justo en medio
de los 2 puntos que teníamos, los cuales eran la intersección con el eje de las "x".
Entonces mi parábola se va a ver más o menos
así, fíjate bien va a subir ahora por aquí, este es el punto más
pequeño que puede tomar mi parábola y si te das cuenta ya no hay de otra, mi parábola, tiene que ser de este estilo ya
no puede ser una parábola que abra hacia arriba. En esta ocasión mi parábola abre hacia abajo, por todo lo que acabamos de ver y
Fíjate bien, si le ponemos el valor a "x" de 0 entonces
interceptamos en el eje de las "y" en -8, en el punto 0, -8
interceptamos al eje de las "y" y espero que te haya quedado bastante claro por que vamos a ver otro ejemplo, de cómo graficámos  más
parábolas. Así que déjame cortar esto primero para que no nos estorbe y tengamos como un pizarrón nuevo.
Perfecto tenemos una pantalla nueva y entonces aquí voy a escribir.
Mi siguiente ejercicio es este, "y" es igual a 2x cuadrada y a esto le voy a sumar
6x y a esto le voy a sumar 4, y ya que la tengo escrita ¿Qué es lo primero que hay que hacer?
Pues claro, factorizar esta expresión para que sea lo más sencilla de resolver, entonces me quedaría "y" es igual y tenemos como factor común al 2
2 que multiplica a "x" cuadrada más 13x más 2
2 por 3 es 6
y 2 por 2 son 4, por lo tanto ya tengo el 2 como factor común, y fíjate la parte de adentro de mi paréntesis.
Esta expresión la puedo factorizar, esto es lo mismo que "x" más 2  que multiplica a "x" más 1,
2 números que sumados me den 3 y que multiplicados me den 2, pues es 2 y es 1, esto es muy claro
ahora lo que voy a hacer es buscar las
intersecciones con el eje de las "x" y para eso, lo que tengo que hacer es igualar esta ecuación a 0
0 es igual a 2 que multiplica a "x" más 2, que multiplica a su vez a "x" más 1
y recuerda que al hacer esto, lo que estoy buscando son las
intersecciones con el eje de las "x" y bueno
2 por "x" más 2 por "x" más 1 es igual a 0.
Si 2 es 0, o si "x" más 2 es 0, o si "X" más 1 es 0, pero 2 nunca es 0, 2 es 2
por lo tanto o "x" más 2 es igual a 0 o "x" más 1 es igual a 0,
por lo tanto déjame escribirlo  aquí.
"x" más 2 es igual a 0 o en su dado caso "x" más 1 es igual a 0,
y bueno de aquí voy a restar 2 de ambos lados de la ecuación y me va a quedar que "x" es igual a -2
y de igual manera, aquí voy a restar -1 de ambos lados de la ecuación y me va a quedar que "x" es igual
a -1 y ya con esto encontré las raíces de esta ecuación y por lo tanto ya tengo que el punto -2,0
y el punto -1, 2 son aquellos puntos de esta parábola que cumplen que
intersectan al eje de las "x", y entonces una vez que ya los tengo los voy a graficar
el -2,0 que es
este de aquí y es más, déjeme poner lo mejor con otro color y voy a hacer también un cambio de escala por que fíjate con
color amarillo se ve muy mal.
Así que déjenme agarrar el color rosa y mejor voy a decir que este es el -1, el -2
el -3 y vamonoss también para acá 1, 2, 3 es decir cada 2 cuadritos es una unidad,
y bueno también para arriba y para abajo.
1,2,3  y -1,-2 y -3 y bueno yo tengo el punto -2,0
y ese es un punto de donde pasa mi parábola y donde cruza al eje de las "x"
por lo tanto lo voy a poner un color verde y al -1,0.  Este punto de aquí también por ahí
pasa mi parábola y bueno
habíamos comentado que entonces para sacar el vértice nos tenemos que fijar en el punto medio en "x" de estos dos valores es decir,
el valor de "x" del vértice es - 2 más - 1 entre 2, lo cual me da -3 entre 2 lo cual es -1.5,
y si yo sustituyó aquí en mi ecuación original el -3/2  o el -1.5
¿Qué me va a quedar? Me va a quedar el valor de "y" pero quién es este valor de "y", va a ser
2 que multiplica a -3/2 elevado al cuadrado
más 6 que multiplica al -3/2 más
4 y bueno ¿Cuándo es esto? Pues vamos a hacerlo. Este es el valor de "y"
del vértice y me queda 2 que multiplica a 9/4 -3/2, elevado al cuadrado son 9/4
y después es 6 entre 2 es 3
3 por -3 me va a dar -9, -9 y después me queda más
4 y 2 por 9/4 es lo mismo que 9/2 ¿Estás de acuerdo?
2 se va con el 4 y me quedan 9/2 -9 y a esto le tengo que sumar 4,
-9 más 4 es lo mismo que -5, de aquí acá esto me da -5 por lo tanto me quedan 9/2 medios -5
y ¿Cuánto es eso? Pues esto es lo mismo que -10/2 y entonces al final me va a quedar 9/2 -10/2
es lo mismo que -1/2 y perfecto ya con esto también tengo el valor de "y" de mi vértice.
Entonces ya puedo dibujar a mi vértice,  mi vértice  tiene el valor de
1.5, -1/2 es decir
este es el punto en donde está situado, mi vértice de mi parábola, así que estoy aquí, y lo tengo que poner justo aquí.
Está perfecto y ya con esto tengo el vértice  de mi parábola y me faltaría saber en dónde corta al eje de las "y", pero si
yo pongo 0 en "x" pues me va a quedar 2 por 0, más 6 por 0, más 4 y me queda el punto 0, 4.
Justo ahí es donde intersecta al eje de las "y", y ahora sí ya puedo dibujar mi parábola, fíjate bien.
Ahora lo voy a hacer para acá, este lado me quedó un poco feo pero bueno,
aquí está mi parábola, justo en medio, está mi vértice y entonces ya tengo mi segundo ejercicio. Si te das cuenta
no estaba tan difícil como pensábamos. Así que vamos a hacer un tercer ejercicio, pues para que todo este conocimiento se asiente bien aquí en
en nuestro cerebro y sepamos perfectamente bien cómo resolver cualquier gráfica de una función cuadrática.
Entonces ahora tengo -"x" cuadrada más 10x -21 y bueno, lo primero que hay que hacer era
factorizar lo más que se pudiera.
Entonces voy a factorizar al -1 y ¿Qué me va a quedar? -1 que multiplica a "x" cuadrada -10x más 21.
Estoy factorizando este -1 por que me gusta más tener a "x" cuadrada
positiva, que tener la negativa y bueno ahora voy a buscar 2 números que multiplicados me den
21 y que sumados me den - 10 y parece ser que 7 y 3, 7 por 3 es 21 y sumados me dan,
bueno si los pongo negativos me van a dar -10, entonces esto me queda de la forma -1
que multiplica a "x" -3 que multiplica a su vez a "x" -7, ya te diste cuenta con la "x" cuadrada positiva,
es mucho más fácil factorizar. Y ahora si -3 por -7 me da 21 positivos y -3 - 7 me da -10.
Y bueno a continuación recuerda que lo que tenemos que hacer es sacar las
intersecciones con el eje de las "x", y para eso lo que voy a hacer es que "y" valga 0, y por lo tanto
me queda 0 es igual a -1 por "x"- 3 por "x"-7 y aquí me queda que
"x"- 3 es igual a 0, en su dado caso "x" -7
es igual a 0 y "x"- 3 es igual a 0 si "x" es igual a 3 y "x" - 7 es igual a 0
si "x" es igual a 7. Y ya con esto ya tengo mis 2 valores en donde se intersectan el eje de las "x" en el
3 y en el 7, estamos aquí en el 3 y estamos aquí en el 7,
aquí también intersecta el eje de las "x", por lo tanto tenemos los puntos
3,0 y 7,0.
Y bueno vamos a sacar el valor del vértice, primero hay que fijarnos en el valor de "x", para esto lo que tengo que hacer
es 3 más 7 entre 2 es decir sacar el punto medio, lo cual me da 5 y ¿Cuánto vale "y" en el vértice? Pues
hay que sustituir este valor en "x" aquí en mi ecuación original, y me quedaría -25 más 10 por 5 lo cual me da
50 -21, 5 por 5 me da 25 por el menos me da -25
10 por 5 me da 50 y esto -21, y aquí me queda -25 más 50 es 25, 25 -21
me da 4 positivo. Entonces de todo esto me queda 4, por lo tanto mi punto del vértice está en el 5,4
mi vértice está situado en el 5,4, déjenme ponerlo por aquí, a ver déjame escribirlo
5,4 es el punto del vértice y entonces tengo que caminar 5, estamos aquí y 4 para arriba,
2, 3, 4 estamos aquí y si te das cuenta el vértice me está quedando
arriba de mis intersecciones ¿Qué quiere decir eso?
Nosotros habíamos encontrado parábolas que abrían hacia abajo, sin embargo esta parábola tiene que abrir hacia arriba, por que si abre hacia abajo
entonces el vértice está situado
abajo de los puntos de intersección, y si te das cuenta en esta ocasión me queda que el vértice está arriba
de mis ejes de intersección, por lo tanto mi parábola
abre hacia arriba y ¿Por qué abrirá hacia arriba? Qué cosa tan rara ¿No?
¿De qué va a depender que abre hacia arriba o que abre hacia abajo una parábola? Déjame
dibujarla un poco mejor, por que no me está quedando
va bien, va bien, perfecto aquí está mi parábola. Y entonces te decía ¿De qué va a depender que mi parábola abra hacia arriba o abra hacia abajo?
Y la respuesta es de este signo menos que yo tengo aquí.
Si el signo de la "x" cuadrada es positivo, entonces mi parábola va a abrir hacia abajo, si el signo de la "x" cuadrada es
negativo, entonces mi parábola va a abrir hacia arriba, como en este caso. Si te das cuenta tenemos un signo negativo y por lo tanto
cambia la dirección de mi parábola, y bueno si te das cuenta, si mi parábola abre hacia abajo,
entonces mi vértice es el punto mínimo de esta parábola, y si mi parábola abre hacia arriba, entonces el vértice va a ser mi punto
máximo. Y bueno entonces nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo.